lawmakers on capitol hill hearing
emotional first-hand accounts of the
devastating human impact of gun violence
in the u.s
he shot my friend that was next to me
and i
thought he was going to come back to the
room so i grabbed the blood
and
i put it all on me and i got my
teacher's phone
and called my own
i told her that we need help
and
[Music]
after her recorded testimony the father
of the 11 year old school shooting
survivor told members of congress that
the family is now dealing with the
subsequent trauma
hello
hello today
i come
because that got lost by baby girl
she's not the same little girl that i
used to play with hanging around with
and do everything because she was
daddy's little girl
i don't know what to do because i think
i would have lost my baby girl
she's everything
not only for me but her siblings and her
mother
but i wish something will change not
only for our kids
but every single kid in the world
because schools are not safe anymore
another parent the mother of a 21 year
old who was severely injured in the
buffalo new york shooting last month
issued a direct appeal to lawmakers you
are elected because you have been chosen
and are trusted to protect us but let me
say to you here today i do not feel
protected
no citizen needs an ar-15 these weapons
are designed to do the most harm in the
least amount of time and on saturday may
14th it took a domestic terrorist just
two minutes to shoot and kill ten people
and injured three others
i can still see her walking with us
toward the exit this mother called for a
ban on the type of assault rifle used to
kill her ten-year-old daughter in uvalde
texas so at this moment
we ask for progress
we seek
to raise the age to purchase these
weapons from 18 to 21 years of age we
seek red flag laws
stronger background checks
we also want to repeal gun manufacturers
liability and unity these are measures
supported by democrats in congress and
echoed by several members during the
hearing
no civilian needs an assault rifle
and the second amendment does not
protect the right to own a weapon of war
it's time that we banned assault rifles
from our streets from our communities
from our homes but even on an occasion
like this the partisan divide is all too
clear
republicans wary of what they call an
assault on the right to bear arms
calling for added security in schools
rather than new gun control legislation
too often tragedies are politicized for
partisan gain and we have seen many seek
to leverage these crimes and their
victims to push for radical left-wing
policies or to betress their campaigns
to get elected
a division reflected in the senate too
where nine republican votes would be
needed to pass any meaningful
legislation
votes that are unlikely to be
forthcoming
on anything other than the most tepid of
measures
mike hanna al-jazeera washington